escala la violencia entre Turquía y las
milicias kurdas este lunes un cohete
disparado desde el kurdistán sirio mató
al menos a tres personas entre ellas un
menor y un profesor en la ciudad turca
de carcamis según el gobierno de ancara
responderemos a los ataques de la manera
más contundente posible tomaremos todas
las medidas necesarias al respecto
la organización terrorista del yepegi
pkk no tendrá ninguna oportunidad de
sobrevivir ni dentro ni fuera de
nuestras fronteras
el gobierno de recepto hiperdogan culpó
a las milicias kurdas de Siria del
atentado bomba del 13 de noviembre en
Estambul que causó la muerte de seis
personas e hirió a más de 80 el pkk y el
ipg niegan la autoría de la explosión
sin embargo como supuesta represalia en
la madrugada de este pasado domingo el
ejército Turco bombardeó el kurdistán de
Siria e Irak y mató al 31 personas la
mayoría integrantes de las fuerzas
curtas aunque también civiles una
operación que desató la indignación de
la población en el noreste de Siria en
almalica miles de personas despidieron
este lunes a 11 de las víctimas mortales
envueltas en la bandera roja amarilla y
verde del kurdistán
hoy lanzamos un llamado al mundo a las
grandes potencias y a todos los que se
preocupan de los Derechos Humanos sea lo
que sea que haga Turquía no romperá la
voluntad del pueblo kurdo no podrán
someternos
según el observatorio sirio de Derechos
Humanos este lunes la Aviación turca
reanudó los ataques sobre el kurdistán
sirio y erdogan advirtió que la
operación no se va a limitar
necesariamente al espacio aéreo el
ejército de Turquía ha entrado tres
veces con tropas al kurdistán sirio